- What's the contribution you have left?
- He gave way more than he took.
- And that's that, and
that's why he's GaryVee.
- You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
Let me give you some like real real advice
that you know, you can trump
because you're in charge,
one man's point of
view, die on your sword,
do not pander to the short-term
situation in the room.
Leave them understanding
that it's very cute
that they decided to go
off of potential reach,
'cause that's what it is.
Nobody gives a fuck about a lot of the ads
that are being serviced on the websites
that they're moving those dollars.
I genuinely believe that what
the internet's doing right now
gives the disproportion advantage
to the people that
start off at the bottom.
Because the cost of
entry used to be blocked
by the people at the top but
now the internet is the game.
- Yeah, it's the gateway to, yeah, yeah.
- Like your world, like MTV had say.
Like, Hot 97 had say, like Casey Kasem,
Dick Clark, Soul Train, TV.
Like SoundCloud has say now.
Like I want to be humongous
I go to SoundCloud
and go put a song up.
- Seriously that's how
I got my following, it's a free
platform and yeah, why not?
- SoundCloud, Spotify, Facebook,
YouTube, Instagram, game over.
All the leverage, the only
people that will have leverage
are the person that makes
it and the audience.
And the way used to be was
everybody in the middle took pieces.
Like guys, MTV did not
play Michael Jackson.
Let's just say it one more
time, like just for you,
like I wanna say it's
so everybody hears it,
MTV did not play Michael Jackson
and until CBS, the
radio, like a production,
the record deal, not
the, said yo, fuck you.
He wasn't on MTV,
somebody had say in 1984.
So that statement is what I want from you.
I want you, in my perfect world,
you would do a podcast every day,
this is like, let me, if I
was a getting complete control
and you were my puppet you
would do a podcast every day
that was filmed and then post produced
for pieces of content for all your shit.
Pinterest, Twitter, Instagram,
LinkedIn, all of it.
- So Gary, listen.
- Yes.
- Having had absorbed
your content, watched you,
I consider you the modern day Robin Hood.
And before I explain what that means
tell me your initial thoughts on this.
- You're smarter than you look.
(laughs)
Honestly, I don't I'm
trying to think right now
'cause I don't want to bullshit,
I think you might be the
first person to say that,
recently, ever maybe even,
and I think it's very interesting
'cause it's crossed my
mind multiple times.
- Here's what I'm getting,
a long time ago there were
these ideas and these thoughts
and these collaborations were for
the super successful, super
rich, the Rockefellers,
all these people and what
you've done is you've said,
alright, no more, you can look at your
Sasha that you just started,
you can look at the way you do things,
and you're making it
available to everybody.
And if that's not Robin
Hood I don't know what is.
- And to your point, Sasha's
as a company I'm building
but like my great legacy
in my aspiration to be
someone that gets written
about like Robin Hood
is giving it for free.
Like the thing that I,
if somebody asked me
what are you most proud of,
I'm literally giving away
all my best shit for free.
I don't know what else to say.
A lot of people that kind of look like me
build audience to the masses
but then try to sell to
that audience, right,
here's the $4,000 ebook, here's
the come to my mastermind.
What I do is, back to your analogy,
this is why I thought of it too,
I do business with Chase and Budweiser
and triple A list celebrities
but for the masses it's free.
Like, I really know what I'm talking about
and when I meet anybody and
anything, by the way, this,
right, we've had to move
this podcast a couple times,
I've got this weird day,
now I come and sit down
and say hey, I got 20
minutes not 30, right,
but like for these next 18 minutes
like I'm giving everything I've got.
Like, I'm not thinking about,
I don't even know what my next meeting is,
I don't, there's a million
fires I have going on,
I don't give a fuck, I
need to deliver to this
and I think that's what I
do well for any audience,
whether it's celebrity,
the masses, client,
like I'm obsessed with over-delivering.
It's why I say yes to shit
like this in the first place.
The fact that I get one
of the emails I get a day
and I get a lot of them that says,
I was suicidal, like
real, shit that's heavy,
that trumps anything I will
ever do professionally.
One, one person telling you
that they were going to take their life
and that your fucking videos
and podcast made them not
is disproportionately greater
than if I bought all 32
NFL teams, and I mean that.
Hey guys thank you so much for
watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at
the end because I'm working on
a ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all
please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink thirty six
bottles of wine a year
or give away thirty six
bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me
and I could really use your support.
(upbeat music)